[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
esclavage lynchage ségrégation
disparités économiques violence le
racisme au péché originel de la mairie
continue de hanter les états unis
[Musique]
certains outils rêve d'égalité ont été
cultivés ici parmi ces parterres fleuris
et ses augustes bâtiment de briques
rouges bienvenus walker ridge au coeur
de la ville d'atlanta en georgie
alma mater de martin atkinson
[Musique]
samuel jackson du liban dans la galerie
qui jouxte la chapelle du collège on
trouve le portrait des afro américains
qui ont marqué l'histoire des états unis
luther king rosa park mais aussi les
grands donateurs qui se font un honneur
de financer la figure de proue du réseau
universitaire noir
aujourd'hui morale due forme des
historiennes les économistes du
scientifique mais peu importe la matière
il y à une attente qui elle ne varie pas
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que des figures connues
pour qui cette université fondée à
l'origine pour indiquer les esclaves
devenu libre est beaucoup plus qu'une
maison enseignement plutôt un gage
d'émancipation le père gerald ford a
obtenu son diplôme en 1949 il est devenu
l'un des premiers médecins noire de
l'état de la georgie lui même
aujourd'hui l'homme d'affaires a obtenu
son diplôme en 1981 sauf que cette fière
qui se paie une véritable petite fortune
en marche
plus de 44 millions d'américains ont des
dettes d'études
au total les dettes d'études s'élève
maintenant à plus de 1500 milliards de
dollars aux états unis
chez razzoli en mai 2019 smith l'un des
afro américains les plus riches des
etats-unis prononce le discours à la
collation des grades soalala vos
souhaits cannabis
[Musique]
le don du milliardaire fait rêver le
cadet de la famille wolford il rêve en
fait à une société où l'éducation serait
la clé mais en 2020 rêver d'une amérique
plus juste est un défi en soi pour les
jeunes diplômés de morale est dit
en tout cas d' georges